foreign
ER commentaries I don't know what camera
I'm on right now this middle middle one
little one who's to say it's the middle
uh I'm trust me I'm here with lawn if
you can't see there he is I'm also here
yeah uh we're back in studio look at
this still set up for a gaming thing but
like I said Life's a game play it I am a
hardcore gamer as you know so it's very
Pro I feel right at home Lon just put
down the sticks uh I was by beat saber
before this I was in a hardcore beat
saber session you could not have named a
more casual game but whatever uh we're
on Australia commentaries we're going to
talk about mathrigan today
um we're gonna go with a little uh my
little Terminator we're going to talk
about our thoughts behind this 90 minute
feature film
um we're going to take your questions so
keep those coming in the chat we'll show
you some deleted scenes and then we'll
tease you with next week's big old
trailer uh that's gonna be that's gonna
be a big one yeah and uh shout out to
Danielle who's not feeling so well today
sorry she couldn't be here is it do not
take this as implying that she didn't
help us right help us write this with a
huge help in terms of the making of it I
need to add her to the credits Bailey
Myers also sent in some jokes Phantom
Zone
um but we're here long and Spenny we're
talking I got my squirt uh
traditional coffee for me yeah but I do
a little with a little bit of squirt in
it oh good yeah I always like to spike
it was like a little sparkling Grapes of
Squirt
that set you off that was it yeah
start start the day sorry it's like the
people who put butter in coffee it's a
little unconventional but I would figure
it more into cream than squirt but you
know listen there's two types
Rush of grapefruit along with your
coffee uh what are we talking about
Megan Meg and Regan yeah uh I guess the
the reason we're goofing around is like
there's not much to this movie and I
liked it um it's a it's a goofy horror
horror comedy
um it it riffs on um parenting and
screen time as we were talking about
before we started just all of our
over-reliance on technology and how it
seeped into sort of every corner we've
had a million evil doll movies through
Annabelle's and Chucky's and stuff like
that um but I thought you know it's the
details that got me I thought the design
of Megan just her like her like really
face that she would give people cracked
me up
um the Rampage the little the mini
Rampage at the end was stupid
um I mean yeah I think I think you're
getting to do what I thought too which
is it's it's funny it's clever I think
Megan is a great character like I feel
like the the real find here is Megan is
a concept as a character is very funny
the movie kind of drags for about 20 30
minutes until we get mega because it's
like a long time of her being designed
and I didn't really care that much and
then but once Megan shows up and she
starts being herself it's it's good and
it's funny and it's very entertaining I
do think the horror elements don't work
as well because it really feels like and
I think this is what happened but it
really feels like an R-rated movie that
was intended to be more like a slasher
thing that then got like you can tell
this is missing this is missing two or
three kills and even the kills that
happen are like we get those like
cutaway at the key moment or like the
the person's being stashed
yeah I don't need to see giblets flying
I just mean that like there are like
this the psychiatrist the therapist yeah
she just disappears and I assume she was
killed in an earlier version but she
just does she just stopped showing up in
the movie listen I'm not saying I'm a
Gore hound and everything has to be
terrifier too like I I get it like this
movie could have been pg-135 but it's
the way that it if it's made to be PG-13
and you're directing the scenes knowing
that you're gonna do it that way I think
there are ways to make it more
suspenseful does it just mean that
there's like a certain Rhythm to horror
movies where it's like even if they're
comedy like Scream It's like jokey scene
relationship scene kill scene uh
oh oh I'm hearing myself yeah we're
hearing ourselves remix
um regardless uh let's stop and start as
we go and head on into the honest
trailer for math Regan
[Music]
you've seen her blow up on Tick Tock pop
up in flash mobs and give talk show
hosts a nervous breakdown
now that Drew Barrymore clip you sent me
the whole thing yeah I recommend
everybody stop this well or after that
yeah and then watch
um Drew Barrymore as Megan yeah just
absolutely have a a breakdown on camera
he's doing a full interview segment with
Allison Williams about the movie and the
bit is okay Drew will dress up and be
Megan for the interview which is a funny
bit I just do it but I don't know this
is like very unsettling about her
performance as well that I can't put my
finger on she should be the next uh
Megan oh I absolutely feel like this is
Drew Barrymore's audition for for M4
again before he should put her in there
for sure she's earned her spot it's it's
like you can't even script it because
her cut her fake contact lens starts
drifting so she looks like a broken
robot um and Alice Williams kind of like
you could tell that she got a little bit
of a download before the show like
listen Drew's got it she's gonna be in
costume Just go with it but she doesn't
really know how to react or engage like
it wasn't really rehearsed and it's so
great it's really wonderful it's good
stuff yeah
I'll catch Megan in her big screen debut
that proves the only success that means
anything in Hollywood these days is
starting a viral dance craze
this is exactly what Black Adam was
missing
so both really good all right I just had
an idea for a screen junkie show is we
create the dances for the movies that
didn't get them yes like the My Dinner
with Andre yeah um the Pelican Brief
I'm just trying to think of movies
yeah no I think for sure Pelican Brief
let us know in the comments what movie
that would never get uh
the dance yeah
hmm so yeah keep those coming in the
chat what movies should get down need
their own day and it will get like a
crew like some studio in the valley to
to choreograph it might dress up new
show you heard it here I realized I did
I left out there was one more pop
culture via recent viral deadly uh
She-Hulk twerking wasn't it that's right
well I mean she didn't invent it wasn't
people twerked long before Tatiana
you're right you're right anyways let's
keep going RR didn't invent the dancing
with your suspenders
experts say the preferred method is to
give your child the choice it's called
The Division and she's generally an
off-putting little creep that no child
would feel safe sleeping next to
oh Jesus Christ you're getting our salad
tossed on girls Allison Williams is back
and this nepo baby has a message for the
haters life isn't fair and it's not fun
to root for her I'm into this with a big
big head start and I feel like it's
totally okay to admit that huh that's a
pretty honest take actually so he's
playing Jim I'm so sad Danielle's not
here should we wade into nepo baby
discourse or do we have a really her
department but uh yeah I mean I I I
agree with you I think that's this is
all people want from from the nepo baby
discourse I I think people always
misread it the celebrities always think
it's more of an attack like we're saying
you don't deserve you don't deserve to
be famous Jamie Lee Curtis and I don't
think anybody who feels deserves to be
famous oh right does anybody deserve
deserve to be here everybody and nobody
deserves to behave I do think that's
true but it's like nobody's saying Kate
Hudson shouldn't be a movie star well I
think everybody likes Kate Hudson I like
Kate Hudson Bowie would you like we just
want that humility and to like be real
about doors were opened for you and you
had to walk through them yourself but
the doors were open right left the door
open they left the key under the mat we
just don't want to hear that deny like
no I had to hurry yeah I had to audition
right I'm sure they didn't know whose
kid you were yeah I think that's what
everybody is sort of tired of hearing
it's it's not that you know the it's
unacceptable to be Jack Quay because
look Jack White's good I like Jack White
I was gonna stupidly ask who's who's
Jack Quinn
not Randy that's a shame no no sadly
he's Dennis and Meg
um I have some good uh some good nepo a
good nepo baby audition story from a
previous job that I'll tell on off
camera
all right keep going
uh a woman who's really more of a Karen
have you seen this dog it is a monster
I'm chasing it off with my property
every other day this girl boss will try
anything to avoid parenting her orphaned
knees except I are a Humanity like a
normal rich white lady but gemma's got
her hands full as spunky's hot shot toy
designer slash lead programmer slash
robotics engineer slash marketing
department she's more than just a toy
she's part of the family that's good
slash girl who builds fighting bags for
fun see that gen Z you have to work at
being a psycho
and we spent a hundred thousand dollars
want to generate sympathy for a kid fast
but don't know how to write try killing
other parents in a car crash
[Applause]
[Music]
pause I think it's so funny that in the
Pokemon when it's like and Mewtwo killed
my man
yeah because I I put together that list
of like here's a bunch of the reasons
what Shazam was the one that jumped out
immediately at me
um and I put that one in there and then
we had a little like slack discussion of
like does this count because it's only
one parent and technically he doesn't
die his soul ends up in a Pikachu
like what what is life I'm in my 40s
folks it's ridiculous there's a lot of
others where
um you know the main character there's
just so many um inciting car crashes
right in a kid's life in film well even
I mean there's this is like the fantasy
superhero version of the Trope it's kind
of a Trope that extends through because
also like I've been watching a lot of
like Nordic noirs and Mysteries and
those also have a lot of like
the killer was orphaned as a boy and now
he's getting Vengeance because you
caused the car accident you know like
there's one of those I think Department
Q movies where that's the twist I was
just trying to stretch to think if there
was any way we could play um Brad Pitt
getting doubly whomped in um black which
is a classic Alzheimer Cliff but no it
doesn't quite fit not quite yeah there's
a little boy who's orphaned by it yeah
all right keep going
like with Jim as niece KD because I
guess being careless with deadly
machines runs in her family we should
have put chains on the car
together Katie Gemma and Megan will play
a Wicked Game of who's the mommy Megan
turn off are you sure until it finally
erupts in an extremely mild third act
Rampage packed with fewer on-screen
kills than a Dragon Ball Z dub
s they're okay because the most
hard-eating Cuts in this horror movie
were the ones they made to make it PG-13
oh good every main character lived see
you in maforgan
so leave the kids at home with an iPad
and enjoy a 90-minute finger wag at
parents who leave their kids at home
with an iPad and what's basically the
poor Pinocchio movie well first of all
actually play this clip because it's my
favorite part of the whole trailer
out in the last 12 months
I hope we can put that over every movie
for 2023. skinny
but uh the in does this movie go over
the line or is it fair in its Judgment
of parents who give their kids screens
you know to raise them or at least to to
babysit them or to buy themselves some
time you were saying that you think it's
too harsh on parents it's a little I
think the one Saving Grace that gets
them out of it is I think most movies
the the girl uh what what Katie I think
she would have been like kind of the
protagonist like a child's play the kid
is it's from the kids perspective and
the fact that this movie is told From
gemma's perspective I think we're on her
side a little bit more than we would be
I think if it was written from Katie's
perspective Gemma would be like the
villain of this movie even more so than
Megan yeah and I feel like that's a
little harsh she's she she is not Oh I
thought she was the villain for sure of
this movie yeah and I mean I don't know
it just it feels it feels a little
pointed and it's kind of like I think
there's a way to do like look kids are
being massively influenced by the
internet and digital media and it's so
much screens that it's so much coming
out of it on time and I think there's a
way to engage with that without making
it like parents are so lazy like I feel
like the perspective is kind of like
judging I mean it but it does play with
as a parent uh it plays with not
apparent so for me it's like yeah great
you all are terrible it plays with a
very real anxiety slash Temptation which
is that which didn't exist when we were
growing up which is
um screens iPads phones whatever it is
like an off button for your child if
they're like at a restaurant or if
they're like annoying you you can just
give them a screen and it's like
that's raising them like yeah I don't
have to do anything else for the next
couple hours while they play with this
thing and that I think can be like a
crutch or a real Temptation that you can
fall into and to see someone do this
um take this to the next level it is
like maybe it is just like playing on my
own insecurities but it's like yeah F
her she's a bad parent dude okay yeah
I think parents would feel judged by the
movie but no if parents are like I'm
better than that better than her I don't
I don't give my kid makeup it's
satisfying in that way because yeah
you're not as bad as Allison will yeah
get her Megan get it okay okay I get
that that makes sense that was that was
my reaction all right keep going
with a little bit to say about
technology a little bit to say about
capitalism and one very big thing they
want to say about parenting it's better
to let the Terminator raise your kid
than to even think about sending them to
Florida
yeah my very first uh reaction was like
where are the grandparents like it does
yeah she keeps saying I don't want like
oh I don't want to sit there it's like
that that actually makes a lot more
sense yeah it raised the kid I and my
wife die my kid is going with like my
grandparents or her grandparents and if
they both die even still my brother is
like
uh I actually was discussing about my
brother's wife is pregnant right now and
so thank you so uh yeah it's like we've
had the same conversation like there's
no way I'm getting this kid right yeah
like we have friends with kids that
she'd she'd be fine with absolutely
childless siblings who are like yeah
workaholic childless siblings my parents
aren't even like they're not even still
together it would be like my dad would
get the kid before me like me that's
come on come folks come on if we said
everybody in the family both sides would
just make a fail they wouldn't even say
anything they just like right and then
second to that uh okay fine she goes
with the cookie Aunt um but uh she's
gonna give her to the doll instead of
hiring a nanny or daycare or anything
she's like I'm Gonna Keep the kid around
me 24 7. I feel I'm just not gonna hire
any help I feel like they made it they
made a storytelling decision early on
that was this movie is going to include
her creating Megan and then giving it to
a kid to like beta test yeah and I feel
like you get out of a lot of the plot
complication stuff if Megan already
exists like I feel like we should have
been further along in Megan's
development because it also it just kind
of stretches credulity or had her like
like her sister more or had a closer
relationship thing it just it kind of
stretches it a little bit that she
creates Megan like overnight in reaction
to this real-time scenario that's
happening in her family it all is very
like kind of and if you had made the
grandparents off-camera evil they're
coming back in before again you get to
cast them as some cool people and that's
a missed opportunity yeah yeah I mean or
or some other explanation for why
they're not in the picture they can't do
it something other yeah
all right keep going orange Pokemon
Elon brosk Katie ratio death lab for
Cutie shrieks and Geeks Real Steel
anyone remember Real Steel and the boss
baby and get me a kombucha I like that
guy shut up Nick
so Jim is definitely going to prison for
life right
I think so at the end I mean she's live
she's got to be the one responsible for
Megan's killing Rampage she also has
some quote about how she put listening
devices and all the Furbies yeah it's
it's a it's a it's a weird we don't ever
really get a scene with like legal where
they're working out this beta test that
Katie's doing like who who does Megan if
Megan is the intellectual property of
that company and it's being kept in a
private home with a kid playing with it
24 7. that's a huge liability issue
they'd have to ensure that like that's
what this movie was we don't have any
information on that so that well Megan
could have killed the lawyers yeah
I feel like that that also would be some
of the implications of like who's on the
who's on the the hook for this who's
liable for this like this the company
cleared it or did Allison Williams Rogue
because if Ellen's Williams was going
rogue then yeah she's like a I think
that was the implication yeah she did
she's a triple murderer I mean just
because I mean Megan was a deadly weapon
if I built a gun that just uh shoots
just never stops shooting and then left
and then left the room like I'm still a
murderer right uh the gun was very sassy
it was so sad it kind of went on its own
and did this because it's so sassy
um it was killing it was serving and it
was serving murder
all right uh what do we do now did we
finish yeah let's watch some deleted
scenes
foreign
see that gen Z you have to work at being
a psycho can't just Google death and
close by on Vibes Gathering auxiliary
internet data on death the end life
holy uh clips from but that's never gone
well is when you teach the robot by like
uh showing it like video clips from the
internet no it always gets the wrong
idea or the right idea yeah
um or in in the case of The Fifth
Element you just have to stop before it
gets to W because that's all the bad
words are in W think about it it we're
we're teaching these robots about
Humanity from like what YouTube Tick
Tock that's not gonna I guess that's not
we're not we're not we're not sending
our best no no folks we're not I mean I
guess you know there'd be some some but
like so there's there are a few Mr Beast
videos in there and the robot would
learn altruism
let's not wade into that one I'm not
ready for that uh keep going
scrabby Megan Sparkle shorts are good
neopet Small Wonders
first kills my robot my bloody my bloody
my bloody and me shouldn't we maybe
program it not to kill hashtag not all
robots Iron Mike Tyson and the team at
wizards of the codes
I want you all to remember this moment
the moment we kicked Hasbro right
and every corporate manager get me a
list of things I can say in a
presentation that makes it sound like I
know what I'm talking about
Toy Story
die robot
short circuit three hard reboot the Meg
battery's not included Pacific Northwest
technically yeah they're toys they're
just um Collectibles so you don't
actually play with them Eminem
personally called out by a movie like
this since Judy didn't stared into my
soul
uh yes the old fourth wall Judy Dench
gotta love it yeah what did you say cats
are not dogs I know I know that I think
everybody knows that
um thank you for watching us and Judy
Dench um thank you for watching Judy
denge specifically yeah every uh Tuesday
live but usually not but sometimes from
studio uh hopefully I mean Emma what a
great job like making the studio over
great this is because like somebody paid
us money to make something for a company
so that's all it took um was for
somebody to like clean up the the studio
and have it working again so hopefully
we can be doing this like weekly now I'd
love to come back every week and chat
with you it's it's an honor and
privilege to leave the house once a week
and only one that's what you get
um we now have uh yeah and like And
subscribe and hit the Bell so you don't
miss you know Small Wonder do you guys
remember you guys remember Small Wonder
that was that 80s syndicated it was
syndicated right I don't even think it
was on a network well really I mean I
definitely I watched it on TV about it
yeah but I think is one of those that
played on like Channel 13 or channel
five not like NBC on yeah uh it was like
an inventor and he created a Megan like
a daughter robot but they just like it
lived with the family and they like lied
to everybody and told them that it was
like their real daughter for some reason
so yeah for no clear reason so like
they'd always have to be like it was
always like Shenanigans like he's got to
go undercover the neighbors are coming
over and she's malfunctioning and
they're gonna know she's a robot yeah
Five Seasons well so we went on forever
you could do that back in the day uh it
was the it was they just found like a
girl who could believably like talk
monotone
let's build an entire show around this
those people are so rich right now
the creators of small ones good for them
so Audrey Bell was the girl onto your
questions um Adam halbert's got a whole
Meg megverse pitch wow facing off
against Megan in a versus movie The Meg
shark Key and peels Megan or Meg from
Family Guy oh
um
there's a Meghan Markle I think that's I
think Meghan Markle yeah well are they
working to I feel like they're working
together well it's one of the classic
verses then they team up again okay yeah
I feel like it's the entire royal family
being wiped out by the two Mega yeah I
think that's uh that's the plot that's
mine
um also he Adam asks uh since the
marketing was designed to turn this into
a cult classic I think that I don't know
if it's designed to it's a happy
accident but is this the successful
version of the morbius marketing I mean
this one this did cause like a social
media frenzy um I think but this was
morbi is the thing that Sony didn't get
was that more it was always ironic with
morbius it looked really bad everybody
thinks Jared Leto's kind of a goofball
and so we were making fun of it yeah I
don't think people were making fun of it
and I think they were genuinely
entertained by it I think it's funny but
on purpose yeah I mean like you know
that that that scene with Ronnie Cheng
where she's dancing in the hallway and
with the with the sword like of course
who wouldn't want to see that movie
James Bond says Megan's just Small
Wonder right yes yes
but all right well he these are from
earlier in the Small Wonder is even more
like it's kind of troubling because it's
like well but what like this Megan has a
reason to exist this like kid is lonely
and needs a friend and well like a toy
and there's a marketing Capital what
like I'm sure it was explained in one of
the 700 episodes but I'm sure whatever
it was it was creepy as well like like
probably a cart orphan car crash yeah
you're just like you don't need to be
raising a robot dog it's probably like
it was like the love of mad at Grandpa
from The Simpsons his daughter got right
over and goes into a small Wonder his
soul got lost a long way to heaven uh
Lewis Valenzuela did you guys see James
Gunn's DC announcement yes no I didn't
so break the news to me oh boy okay uh
so we're gonna it's a it's a new
Superman uh story rebirth I think it's
called that he's writing we're also
gonna get like a grim dark uh gritty
Super Girl movie plus they're doing this
one is real I made fun of this on
Twitter and then everybody yelled at me
that it sounds awesome so maybe I'm I'm
turned around uh the Green Lantern show
is being re-imagined as a like True
Detective with Green Lanterns
but I don't know there's yeah
okay there's an animated show with a
bunch of like obscure characters the
name of which I'm blanking on that he is
working on there's also a peacemaker
spin-off that's going to Center on a
viola Davis's Amanda Waller just called
Waller
uh and those are the big ones that I
recall okay look
it's all in the execution every Swamp
Thing we're also getting a Swamp Thing a
new Swamp Thing sure I mean the fact
that like pretty much all the all the
fertile soil has been uh mined as far as
superhero titles and IP and content like
another Superman sure like it could be
great it could be terrible nothing about
any of those characters seeing them on
screen is exciting Green Lantern you had
me until you said True Detective right I
feel like and I wrote like that's a
weird combo and everybody was like
they're cops in space buddy cops and
it's like yeah buddy buddy that's not
true detective so serious and self-aware
like I don't know like hell Jordan stop
stop cheating on your way yeah like
leave the weapon in space yes I mean bad
boys in space sure let's do it but I
don't I thought that was kind of an
opportunity there's one more I forgot up
there's gonna be just the green like
cigarette forming out of the ring I
wrote like a whole thing like like the
Vince Vaughn Colin Farrell kind of
scenes in the bar except they're just in
Space Taylor Kitsch jerking himself off
you've got a magic ring you put it on
you got will power suddenly you ain't
got no willpower I don't think these
people have seen True Detectives the man
gets a ring he goes to space and then
he's really a man duh the yellow King
yeah
sinestros was the yellow King all along
there's one more big one I forgot
there's a new Batman movie not our path
so this is separate from the Reeves
verse that's going to be focused on his
relationship with Damien Wayne they're
calling it The the Brave and the Bold so
it's new Robin new Batman they're gonna
do like a sort of a separate Brave in
the Bold verse look all of those could
be great I just hearing the names of the
characters does nothing for me anymore
but seeing something and I will say it
could be really good I will say I
haven't read the Supergirl Arc I guess
that this is based on but I think that's
a really cool idea Supergirl's one of
those characters that we've like one
time in the 80s got on the big screen
and like they should definitely be doing
more who's Superman who's their Superman
we don't we don't have it we don't have
announcers not not the only two people
we know for sure definitely they're
absolutely done in this universe are
Cavill and Affleck yeah everybody else
is like up for grabs potentially got it
all right uh Matan valenski what do you
think about the two Leslie situation in
the Oscars the the influence campaign
yeah I mean uh I don't peop like I get
the
nobody like really saw or cares about
and everybody has like other nominees
they would have rather seen get in but
like I don't feel like they how could
that be against the rules they just a
bunch of people tweeted what would you
even make the rule to make that against
the rules celebrities can't tweet when
they like it yeah just ban ban
campaigning yeah I mean because like if
you're if you're saying like
multi-million dollar ad campaigns where
we blanket the city with Billboards and
every trade that is filled with ads and
fyc everything if that's okay and like
screenings at every Guild or whatever if
all that's okay how then how could like
a few celebrities sending Tweets be nice
I'm just shocked that it worked because
like uh say what you will about the
academy but the membership has grown
they've like times 10 to the membership
over the last few years so you've got to
really you gotta really pound the
pavement to get it I need to get someone
nominated like the visibility of that
movie did like because once this started
it was a lot of it was the interaction
of like what's happening like why are
all of these people suddenly tweeting
this and I think even that Curiosity LED
it to go wider yeah yeah uh well did you
read about how it happened well sort of
the I know the Beats like yeah it was
like the directors wife is Mary
McCormick who acted in that movie
private parts with Howard Stern and I
guess they're still friends yeah so she
went on Howard Stern and encouraged him
to watch the movie and he did and then
he started talking it up and then that
was how they got the ball rolling and
from there she contacted Charlize Theron
and hosted a screening for some other
celebrities and then they hired a PR
firm and it was just like step by step
by step this is like that hi Howard hi
yeah it's like it's crazy like they
called two friends and they called two
friends and it really like grew kind of
in that organic way and it's like I need
to hear about Andre into Leslie
yeah it's uh and I do I'm saying that
like people are like well but not every
actor has that Network you know they
don't all have every other actor that
they can get in touch with and be like
hey Gwyneth tweet about my movie but
it's like but it's not fair regardless
like it's not like it wouldn't be fair
without Twitter the Oscars are silly
make it yeah they're not fair like every
part of the process is not fair
um all right we'll end with this
um he says top three movies I'm just
gonna say top movie daisu psychoro top
movie where there's a number or
non-alphabetic letter in the title
whoa any number so I mean we're talking
like all sequels are on the table I
guess they all have numbers that's
actually really hard if you include
every sequel right because then it's
like well Godfather Part Two is like
kind of right there that's a pretty good
one lucky number seven oh [__] that's so
close so close but like if you eliminate
let's eliminate sequels that makes it
more yeah yeah it's got to be a right
off the bat you gotta because then I was
like my first place I go is like well 12
Monkeys 12 Monkeys is great I really
enjoyed 10 Cloverfield Lane that popped
into my head I like that one but that's
a sequel crap um no it is that
technically is seven the number in there
seven seven seven it's seven beautiful
names it's seven folks seven
all right we'll be back next week
um we will be covering a film
uh
uh it's a film it's a it's definitely a
big movie long it's long
um it it could take an eternity to watch
oh
um and there's your clue for next week
uh we'll see you back here maybe in
studio hopefully on Australia
commentaries thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]